annalena baerbock bei uns haben sie mit
herrn kubicki ausschuss elfi gemacht
frau bärbel
aber heute aber schon nett miteinander
gesprochen der verhandelt hiermit da
sind schützengräben die müssen
überwunden werden oder man geht
aufeinander zu und vergiss das alles ja
wahlkampf ist wahlkampf und die menschen
in deutschland haben entschieden und ich
glaube die letzten wochen haben deutlich
gemacht dass es jetzt nicht nur bezahlt
es für große herausforderungen für große
politische aufgaben sondern auch eine
einmalige chance für eine andere art von
politik vielleicht wir sind ja auch eine
andere generation von politikern
wo viele junge menschen sagen es soll
nicht mehr so viel gelagert werden um es
mal auf deutsch zu sagen sondern die
großen dinge müssen endlich angepackt
werden oder ausgerechnet diese beiden
parteien haben sich ja so eine art
kultur kampf geliefert hätten er würde
ihnen nennen also die die große freiheit
versus die klimaschutz partei die alles
verbieten möchte würde ihnen denn heute
einer dieser sätze die sie gesagt haben
leitungen
dollar belasten fahrrädern nun ja
bullerbü war ja ein zitat die
spitzenkandidaten der grünen hier im
land berlin sprach davon sie wolle aus
unserer hauptstadt ein boule abi machen
also insofern das war ja deshalb 390 auf
naja ich habe jetzt gar keine
verunglimpfung sommers war ein zitat und
klar ist auch das bündnis 90 die grünen
und die fdp unterschiedliche ansichten
haben übrigens die fdp hat auch andere
ansichten als cdu und csu in vielen
fragen der demokratie wo zu führen wir
wahlkämpfe wenn es nicht auch politische
unterschiede gibt und die werden da
heraus gearbeitet jetzt ist der
wahlkampf zu ende und nun müssen wir aus
unterschiedlichen perspektiven uns
aufeinander zubewegen und müssen schauen
wo gibt es gemeinsames und wo gibt es
unterschiede die wir überbrücken können
genau dieser prozess läuft jetzt ich bin
sicher wenn es gelingt ein solches
bündnis von sozialdemokratie grünen und
fdp zusammen zu bringen dann kann das
für unsere landes land gutes bewirken
und ein gewinn sein sagen sie sie haben
sich interessanterweise an vielen
stellen gesetz dazu werden wir noch
kommen freuen uns aber norbert röttgen
in der runde zu begrüßen außenpolitiker
der union und ehemaliger umweltminister
für den parteivorsitz auch irgendwie
angetreten und versucht das
gegebenenfalls jetzt wieder herr röttgen
wie sehr schmerzt ihnen das herz zu
sehen dass sie mit frau bär burg und
herrn lindner auch hätten verhandeln
können in einer jamaika konstellation
also wie sehr schmerzt ist das nicht tun
zu können und jetzt die scherben der
union zusammen zu kehren naja also
natürlich ist das ein schmerz wenn man
eine wahl verliert das ist gar keine
frage
und es ist noch besonders schmerzhaft
weil wir sie so verloren haben nicht nur
24 prozent sondern wir haben ja in fünf
bundesländern kann direkt mandat mehr
gewonnen und darum haben wir jetzt zwei
aufgaben die aber nicht schmerzhaft sind
als aufgabe sondern die muss man
annehmen wir müssen als cdu und csu uns
wieder begründen als volkspartei wenn
das so bleibt wie es jetzt war bei
diesem wahlergebnis dann wären wir nicht
mehr volkspartei ist eine wirkliche
aufgabe und die zweite aufgabe die wir
haben das ist die zweitschönste aufgabe
in der demokratie das ist opposition
klar ist man immer lieber regierung aber
dass nach 16 jahren das mal kommt es
jetzt auch keine nur überraschung ich
habe auch vorher gesagt das ist nicht
selbstverständlich dass müssen wir
besonders begründen nach dieser zeit das
ist uns nicht gelungen und diese aufgabe
beide aufgaben müssen wir uns jetzt
müssen wir jetzt annehmen aber sonst ist
da aber jetzt gibt es neue aufgaben sie
haben immer sehr viel schwarz grünen
geworben sie dann auch an dieser
sogenannten pizza-connection
und heute sagt armin laschet nach
ansicht des sondierungs papiers vieles
davon hätten wir auch haben können sehen
sie das genauso oder sagen sie ralph
brinkhaus hat recht und das ist die
linkeste agenda die deutschland je hatte
also das erste würde ich mal jetzt so
[Musik]
ungeschützt sagen schwarz grün das haben
die grünen und die cdu vermasselt in
diesem wahlkampf das wäre drin gewesen
und das haben beide parteien nicht
hinbekommen und darum gibt es jetzt eine
andere konstellation und das ist ich
glaube dass das die gesellschaftliche
situation jetzt wieder gegeben hätte
dass das auch die veränderung
reflektiert das haben wir beide aber
nicht geschafft die grünen nicht
geschafft und die cdu hat es nicht
geschafft das sondierungs papier da
wurde ich weder das eine noch das andere
sagen ich finde beim sondierungs papier
ist das auffälligste dass da noch es ist
ja nicht der koalitionsvertrag aber es
ist ein erstes papier da ist noch ganz
wenig politik drin also die klima
regierung die sie versprochen haben die
steht da noch nicht drin in zehn tagen
fängt der die weltklimakonferenz die
cops 26 im glas geworden da wäre schon
gut wenn langsam mal rüber kommt was die
neue regierung die ampel regierung die
das ganze erst jetzt weder links noch es
ist etwas was mit einem sehr
ordentlichen gesagt ich glaube das war
im eifer des gefechtes gesprochen das
ist kein realistisches urteil aber das
was da drin steht ist im wesentlichen
die beschreibung zum einen des status
quo also keine steuererhöhung ist ja die
rechtslage kein tempolimit ist ja die
rechtslage die verfassung einzuhalten
beim schuldenmachen ist ja die
rechtslage das ist noch kein aufbruch
sondern ist der status quo den ich im
wesentlichen begrüße aber noch kein auto
haben keine übrigen und im übrigen
empfängt der politik daran wenn ich sage
das sind die schönen ziele die wir
erreichen wollen und das sind die
instrumente und das ist die frage wen
und wege und da war noch fast würde
sagen praktisch nichts drin darüber gilt
es zu diskutieren christiane hoffmann
ist bei uns geschätzte kollegin vom
spiegel vor hoffen nun haben wir alle
zur kenntnis genommen welche großen
worte da unterwegs war jahrhundert
reform wirklich neues in diesem land
aufbruch x-mal wird es gelingen wenn man
das vorweg gibt oder ist es schwierig an
so einem anspruch auch dann ja täglich
gemessen zu werden ich glaube schon dass
es schwierig ist also werden dieses
sanierungspakt hier
erweckt ja den eindruck als hätte man da
ein gemeinsames projekt so wie es rot
grün hatte 1998 als man gesagt hat wir
wollen cool abwählen und wir haben auch
eine agenda was wir mit diesem land
vorhaben gemeinsam
und das was wir heute haben ist ja kein
kein bündnis das eine gemeinsame agenda
hat und schon gar nicht damit gemeinsam
wahlkampf gemacht hätte sondern wir
haben letztlich ein zweckbündnis das
zusammenkommt weil das jetzt hier
möglich ist mal ein wort vom montag ja
ich weiß ja dass ich habe das zur
kenntnis genommen und dass ich das sehe
ich wirklich in frage genauso was
arbeiten dass daraus liebe wird aber das
sanierungs papier das sie ja mit
verfasst haben spiegelt das gar nicht
wider sondern da ist sehr stark die rede
von einem tatsächlich projekt da kommt
in dieser sozusagen präambel mehrfach
das wort aufbruch innovation wandel
modernisierung und man hat den eindruck
da sind drei zusammen die haben wirklich
ein ende haben etwas großes vor mit
deutschland und wenn es dann aber ins
unterholz der einzelnen paragraphen geht
dann tritt unweigerlich so eine
enttäuschung ein weil man denkt wo ist
das denn ich glaube dass das aber kein
widerspruch ist auf der einen seite
sehen wir das kaum vier wochen dass die
bundestagswahl her ist sich in
deutschland schon die stimmung verändert
hat es gibt große erwartungen es gibt
auch eine neugier und ganz
offensichtlich den wunsch nach
veränderung so wurden grüne und fdp etwa
insbesondere von jüngeren menschen
gewählt und fraud mann hat völlig recht
natürlich ist zu beginn einer möglichen
ampelkoalition der vorrat an
gemeinsamkeiten noch überschaubar darin
scheint mir aber das besondere zu sein
wenn nämlich sozialdemokraten und grüne
auf der einen seite und die fdp als
partei der bürgerlichen mitte die
einzige gegenwärtig regierungsfähige
bürgerliche parteien sich auf ein
gemeinsames projekt verständigen und zum
beispiel unsere soziale marktwirtschaft
zu einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft
weiterentwickeln um nur den einen punkt
zu nennen dann wird aus dem als
zweckbündnis
gestarteten projekt vielleicht im
nachhinein etwas was unser land
wesentlich voran gesagt weil man eine
größe die gefahr ist doch dass eben
sozusagen die rhetorik und das was da
tatsächlich steht auseinanderklaffen ich
kann schon verstehen dass politik auch
so funktioniert dass man mal ein ideal
setzen muss oder schuss rhetorik braucht
klar aber wenn es zu weit auseinander
klafft dann spüren dass die leute
natürlich sehr schön glaube olaf scholz
ist wir haben gesamten politischen leben
noch nicht an überschuss an leidenschaft
aber dann sagt er das ja ohne ton das
jahrhundert früher
mal jemand der sich auch mit der gabe
der rede ausgesprochen gut auskennt
herfried münkler ist herzlich begrüßt in
münchen
politologe
politikwissenschaftler ein begeisterter
verfolger der aktuellen politik der auch
viele amtierende
volksvertreter berät er kennt sich auch
mit machiavelli aus und mit den mythen
der deutschen und mit vielem mehr aber
hat mit faszination sicherlich nun auch
diese sondierungsgespräche verfolgt herr
münkler da ist in der tat die rede von
ampel lametta und einer sozialliberalen
öko poesie wir haben hier auch schon die
frage gewendet ob man es hätte ein
bisschen kleiner machen sollen was sagen
sie
ich glaube dass die verhandler da sehr
geschickt herangegangen sind an die
sache sie haben ja jetzt schon
herausgearbeitet welche unterschiede es
vorher gab in der mall kam von der
programmatik und
diese dieser risse oder dieser zwiespalt
den hat man überbrückt indem man mit
bestimmten nation oder negativen
gewissermaßen ein projekt formuliert hat
von dem man sagen kann das ist weit
angelegt das hat eine perspektive das
hat natürlich eine gewisse
verwundbarkeit also die punkte in frau
auch mal angesprochen hat zur folge
nämlich
mein mann liegt einen maßstab hin an dem
man selber gemessen wird aber
gleichzeitig ist diese überbrückung
sozusagen von erwartungshorizont und
erfahrungsraum
gewissermaßen die voraussetzung dafür
dass man ein projekt schmiedet das eben
nicht nur eine legislaturperiode und
dann sind möglicherweise wieder andere
verhältnisse
sondern das geeignet ist ein relativ
langen zeitraum zu umfassen und das fand
ich es ausgesprochen geschickt gemacht
worden damit hat man sich aber natürlich
auch
eine last für das projekt gelegt wenn
man jetzt genügen muss die wirklich groß
ist und wo auch den worten irgendwie
taten folgen müssten
dann kommen wir doch vielleicht mal zu
dieser frisch begründeten jahrhundert
koalition
es wird das größte industrielle
modernisierungsprojekt ist deutschland
wahrscheinlich seit über 100 jahren
durchgeführt hat
alter schwede
und wir dachten schon wir hätten bloss
eine neue regierung gewählt mitnichten
jetzt rollt bald die jahrhundertreform
übers land kleine schritte sind out
diese ampel will geschichte schreiben
darunter läuft nix
milliardenschwere investitionen bei
angezogener schuldenbremse ist es gar
nicht machbar dieser spagat sehr viel
mehr geld ausgeben zu wollen 50 60
milliarden euro mehr pro jahr
gleichzeitig keine mehreinnahmen also
sprich keine zusätzlichen steuern und
man will auch noch die schuldenbremse
einhalten die man schon ohne die
mehrausgaben verfehlen würde
sichere renten stabile beiträge und
nicht einen tag länger arbeiten
ifo chef clemens fuß kritisiert mit
nachhaltiger finanzpolitik sind diese
renten beschlüsse nicht vereinbar die
rentenreform wird offenbar schlicht
vertagt
kohleausstieg
2030 naja idealer weise versteht sich
zukunft und idealerweise eine zukunft zu
haben dass es eben nicht was wir
brauchen
und ganz modern und digital soll alles
in der republik nur noch halb so lang
dauern selbst antworten des künftigen
kanzler super was wäre denn das
beispielsweise da gibt es ja eine ganze
reihe von steuerlichen subventionen und
anderen subventionen die wollen wir
stück für stück sagen sie mal bei
spielen da ein beispiel ich möchte aber
dem nicht vorgreifen dass wir jetzt mit
einem ganz anderes vorgenommen haben
damit wir eine gute zukunft haben
entziehen
ein bisschen bei den worten geblieben
frau berbalk butter bei die fische
finanzierung ist eines der härtesten
themen bei diesen verhandlungen sagen
sie und trotzdem der sehr schön wenn es
seriös wäre wie herr fritsche bei ihnen
irgendwie in den groben richtlinien erst
mal nichts finden und attestieren können
ja der finanzbereich ist einer der
schwierigsten weil da gerade fdp und wir
grünen auch am weitesten auseinander
liegen und nichts desto trotz muss man
jetzt die lösung dafür finden und
deswegen haben wir in diesem sondierungs
papier neue wege gewählt es wurde ja
rentenbeitrag gerade über die frage
rente gesprochen wo wir zum beispiel
einen neuen weg gegangen sind die ja
stand jetzt nicht in unserem
wahlprogramm über diesen aktienfonds
aber bleiben wir vielleicht mal bei der
finanzierung also ist es möglich auf der
einen seite zu sagen wir wollen
die wir wollen investitionen wir wollen
im groben uns an der schuldenbremse
orientieren und brauchen auf der anderen
seite aber eben keine steuererhöhungen
die jetzt nicht in diesem sondierungs
papier sind
das wie rechnet sich das das geht das
wird nicht einfach und wir müssen jetzt
klar trennen weil es sind auf der einen
seite haben wir zum beispiel gesagt wir
sollten den spitzensteuersatz erhöhen um
mittlere und niedrige einkommen zu
entlasten
das ist nicht dabei deswegen können wir
im unteren bereich auch keine entlastung
vor dem hätten uns anders gewünscht aber
wir haben uns jetzt so drauf
wahrscheinlich auf die krisen
investitionen die angesprochen wurden
sind von 50 milliarden 60 milliarden
sanken sie jetzt die sind da schon drin
und darüber haben sie sich verständigt
oder sagen sie das ist noch ein offener
punkt ob wir auf diese in zehn jahren 50
milliarden jeweils kommen ehrlich wir
brauchen mindestens jährlich 500 mir an
und wir haben und mindestens darauf
verständigt weil all das was wir
beschrieben haben bei der
digitalisierung bei der frage
klimaschutz beim umbau der industrie und
da vielleicht erst einmal noch
aufgreifen ja das ist eine
jahrhundertaufgabe so wie wir vor 100
jahren diesen wohlstand des landes auf
fossilen energien auf technologien
aufgebaut haben gilt es jetzt das ganze
klimaneutral zu machen und klar sind die
ansprüche hoch aber wenn wir nach jahren
der stagnation wo sich vieles nicht
bewegt haben was sie aber in corona
gesehen haben nicht sagen jetzt müssen
sich manche dinge wirklich radikal
verändern dann werden wir dieses
jahrhundertprojekt einen klimaneutralen
wohlstand zu schaffen nicht stemmen
können und auf die frage mit blick auf
die investitionen
da werden wir im rahmen der
schuldenbremse kredite aufnehmen darauf
haben wir uns verständigt das ist bei
jedem unternehmen so das sagt meine
maschine im rahmen der schuldenbremse
die schuldenbremse legte eigentlich fest
dass man sich nur um 0 35 prozent pro
jahr verschulden darf sagen sie sie
wollen jetzt noch mal einen richtigen
schluck aus der pulle nehmen im jahr
2022 das unterstellt man verstanden zu
haben aus ihren äußerungen dass es noch
spielräume gebe sich da in 20 22 ein
ordentliches polster anzulegen oder
sagen sie eigentlich reichen uns dann
diese einmal im jahr 50 milliarden die
wir zusätzlich brauchen es gibt jetzt
ist leider ist es immer dass es beides
und es ist auch nicht so deswegen ich
meine klar wenn man jetzt die rollen
wechselt das ist immer so als wäre
opposition waren war das auch so aber es
ist ja nicht so als hätte das es bisher
nicht gegeben wir haben zum beispiel die
deutsche bahn da ist es auch so dass sie
als eigenständiger akteur
eben kredite aufnehmen kann wir haben
die kfw auch die investiert und es ist
auch im rahmen der europäischen regeln
möglich dass wenn man zb einnahmen
generiert dass man dann auch
entsprechend kredite dafür aufnehmen
kann und das brauchen wir alles um die
riesigen großen projekte werden in der
studie nun wirklich angeben zu müssen
wir unbedingt christian lendner zuhören
frage nummer eins verlierer ist in aus
ihrer sicht in diesem sondierungs papier
festgehalten dass in jedem jahr in den
nächsten zehn jahren 50 milliarden
investitionen gebraucht werden und dass
die zusätzlich finanziert werden also
ich kann den satz kleine im rahmen der
gesetzlichen schuldenbremse die nötigen
zukunftsinvestitionen gewährleisten sind
diese 50 milliarden pro jahr da für sie
dabei es gibt noch keine mittelfristige
finanzplanung das wäre auch zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt weder seriös noch möglich wir
kennen ja etwa die konjunkturelle
entwicklung gar nicht und die
konjunkturelle entwicklung bestimmt etwa
auch die größenordnung die die
schuldenbremse an nettokreditaufnahme in
den nächsten jahren erlaubt deshalb ist
hier kein besetztes
relativ das ist gegenwärtig noch nicht
möglich um einmal zu beschreiben wie das
gelingen kann bin ich auf einige aspekte
hinweisen der erste aspekt ist dass es
aus unserer sicht zwingend erforderlich
ist die wirtschaftliche dynamik in
deutschland zu stärken wir haben ein
beklagenswert geringes wachstumsniveau
auch im vergleich zu anderen
europäischen ländern das beschränkt
natürlich die einnahmemöglichkeiten auch
die stadt das eine prosperierende
wachsende wirtschaft stellt natürlich
dem staat auch mehr mittel zur verfügung
zum zweiten sind die investitionsmittel
die jetzt in den haushalten in den
vergangenen jahren eingeplant war
niemals abgeschlossen
weil die planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren und demokratisch
war das wollen wir jetzt ändern
das wäre übrigens einen durchbruch in
deutschland zum dritten auch innerhalb
des haushaltes gibt es spielräume allein
in diesem jahr seit jahresanfang bis
jetzt ist etwa eine milliarde euro an
subventionen gezahlt worden für plug in
hybridautos auch für gutverdiener eine
ganze milliarde euro man fragen muss ob
das eigentlich noch angemessen ist ob
das erforderlich ist da sein das ist
quatsch weil es darüber wird darüber
wird zu sprechen sein ich mache jetzt
nur auf worüber gesprochen wird nicht
was entschieden gestalten sie dass ich
einen punkt von annalena baerbock
aufgreife den ich richtig finde
wir haben ja das ziel private
investitionen zu aktivieren sind
milliarden ich will sagen billionen euro
privaten kapitals in deutschland
vorhanden die aber für viele wichtige
aufgaben nicht eingesetzt werden können
jetzt das nicht in details ausführen
warum und unsere öffentliche förderbank
die kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau kann
ein instrument sein mit dem wir dieses
private kapital das übrigens sehr gering
verzinst ist dass das eingesetzt werden
kann um auch die transformation der
wirtschaft mitzufinanzieren ziehen und
deutschland stützt das kann ich mir
vorstellen dass wir ein ganz spannendes
instrumentarium finden das
undemokratische
schattenhaushalte außerhalb des
bundeshaushaltes verhindert die
schuldenbremse einhält und gleichzeitig
marktwirtschaftlich auch mit privater
haftung fortschritt organisiert indem
sie diese investitionen dann
entsprechend absichern und trotzdem noch
mal die frage was ihr zukünftiger
potenzieller koalitionspartner versteht
annalena baerbock versteht das jetzt in
jedem jahr 50 milliarden
investitionen getätigt werden einfach da
habe ich gesagt weil der werte
geschaffen werden weil es ganz wichtig
ist klimaneutral und gleichzeitig
reicher zu werden die argumentation
kennen sie und parallel dazu möchte man
das jahr 2022 nur ganz kurz dass wir
jetzt ein anderer vorbeireden bei
christian lindner hat ja gesagt wenn
noch keinen finalen kassensturz gemacht
was aber klar ist weil wir orientieren
uns ja gemeinsam an den fakten an dem
was auch ökonomen berechnen der bdi ist
heute raus gegangen und hat gesagt
investitionen sind noch viel höher die
rechnen mit fast
100 milliarden die wir gemeinsam
brauchen also dass wir diese riesige
investitionssummen stemmen müssen das
ist ja keine neue erkenntnis der ampel
sondern das ist das was wir in den
letzten jahren in gutachten immer wieder
gelingt haben wir möglich geworden ist
und das werden wir jetzt im
koalitionsvertrag aus buchstabieren in
welche bereiche dass das alles gemeinsam
einfließen okay noch mal die frage an
herrn lindner nur weil ich möchte dass
sie auch verstanden haben dass ich sie
gefragt habe für annalena baerbock
geschehen zwei dinge in der zukunft auf
jeden fall ich dolmetschen uhr es wird
im jahr 2022
den versuch geben so viel geld wie
möglich in diesen potentiellen haushalt
zu holen weil es noch keine
schuldenbremse gibt sondern eine
ausgesetzte schuldenbremse und ab 20 23
dann 50 milliarden pro jahr versteht der
zukunft vielleicht der zukünftige
finanzminister das auch so
wir haben eine haushaltsplanung für das
jahr 2022 die schuldenbremse ist
ausgesetzt worden wegen
pandemie nicht wegen transformation der
wirtschaft und ich glaube dass das
gemeinsame verständnis aller drei
parteien die jetzt verhandeln ist dass
wir seriös
auch in der haushalts und finanzpolitik
bleiben deshalb habe ich annalena
baerbock anders verstanden als sie
gerade versucht haben zu dolmetschen und
zum anderen ist meine feste überzeugung
dass die von ihnen genannte investitions
zahl an öffentlichen und privaten
investitionen zusammengenommen
wesentlich oberhalb von 50 milliarden
euro liegen wird und dazu wird eine
zukünftige bundesregierung ihren
wichtigen beitrag leisten durch
öffentliche investitionen aber auch
durch neue
marktwirtschaftlich kompatible
instrumente mit denen wichtige vorhaben
auch mit privatem kapital unterstützt
werden und ich bin sicher dass es
gelingt auch die anliegen die bündnis 90
die grünen zu recht öffentlich vortragen
sehr seriös und nachhaltig zu
finanzieren
dann nickt er und jetzt gehen wir mal
ganz kurz zu der journalisten kollegin
vom spiegel frau hoffmann es ist ja viel
von voodoo wirtschaft und politik
gesprochen wurde neben wahlkampf die mit
der einerseits von der fdp und angeblich
eben auch von der union auf dem tisch
gelegen hätte besteht die gefahr dass
auch diese zukünftige ampel
märchen
finanz stunden macht also bis jetzt sie
jedenfalls nicht das ist tatsächlich
schon seriös wäre da da halte ich mich
auch an das was hier die ökonomen gesagt
haben bis jetzt geht das nicht auf was
da aber aber wie in dem in dem
finanzteil steht ja auch keine einzige
zeile drinnen es ist der kürzeste teil
in dem gesamten sanierungs papier
vielleicht auch kein zufall also ich
glaube dass das einfach noch eine
riesige baustelle für die
koalitionsverhandlungen
und wenn nicht das jetzt in dem gespräch
eben wirklich klar geworden ist wie das
gelöst werden soll wenn ich auch noch
herrn lindner so verstehe dass das was
gemeinhin als möglicher ausweg
angesehen wurde nämlich dass man 20 22
eben doch klima schulden macht obwohl
man eigentlich nur corona schulden
machen dürfte wenn sie das jetzt aber
auch sagen das ist aber fortmann
spiegel doch als
unseriös und als ein geburtsfehler einer
neuen koalition
brandmarken und deshalb sollte es eine
solch auch immer wenn man die die
bestehenden wegen der korona pandemie
eröffneten
kreditermächtigungen jetzt nutzt um
gewissermaßen einen vorrat anzulegen für
eine neue koalition das wäre nicht
seriös nicht ausschließen das finde ich
finde ich sozusagen finde ich
interessant das will aber er hat es
interessante klar sei aber dass das mal
so sagen darf das waren vorschläge von
ökonomen herr fust hat das in der welt
am sonntag ja in einem gastbeitrag
geschrieben und er selbst hat schon drei
argumente vortragen müssen was man alles
tun muss damit das überhaupt legitim
sein kann also das war ja mit größter
vorsicht und ich sage ihnen worauf man
es wird ein finanztableau geben und auch
eine planung für investitionen die aus
der dekarbonisierung der wirtschaft der
digitalisierung der modernisierung des
staates ein wachstumsprojekt für unser
land macht nur wir leben auch in einer
zeit mit beginnender inflationsrisiken
der kommen können innovation
nachhaltigkeit der öffentlichen
mich beunruhigt noch etwas anderes daran
und das ist das vollkommene fehlen der
umverteilungs idee dass sie haben das ja
angesprochen sie haben das gewollt und
das sozial abfedern
hier kommt er gleich noch mal gehen
würde nämlich sekunde ich würde sie
vergessen sich ich möchte in norbert
röttgen noch mal fragen ist es
vielleicht auch einfach echt pech dass
diese ampel koalition startet in einer
zeit wo 480 milliarden corona schulden
aufgelaufen sind die letzte große
startete glaube ich mit 70 milliarden
plus
und man marschiert er jetzt eben so oder
so in eine wirklich harte zeit hinein
und möchte weder schattenhaushalte weil
davor warnt der bundesrechnungshof und
man möchte auch vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht landen
weil so eine rücklage durch das
grundgesetz nicht gedeckt sei was tun
also
egal wer regiert das regieren in den
nächsten jahren machen einschlafen würde
das müssen sie ja dann die betroffenen
fragen es ist jedenfalls hart sie haben
völlig richtig gesagt das sind wenn wir
den haushalt 2022 noch dazu nimmt der
ist ja im kabinett beschlossen worden
dann sind es 470 milliarden 470
milliarden euro neuer schulden in einen
so kurzen zeitraum wurden noch nie so
viele schulden gemacht die flut hilfen
von 30 milliarden sind noch nicht dabei
und wir haben diesen
investitionsbedarf wir haben den
transformationsberatung darum muss ich
sagen die das bislang rechnerisch noch
nicht auf aber das gespräch bringt immer
weitere klarstellung und frau hoffmann
und eben auf eine klarstellung
hingewiesen dass es nicht rechtlich
zulässig nicht legitim ist den großen
schluck wegen pandemie nun für andere
investitionen zu nehmen hat christian
lindner klar gestellt er hat desweiteren
klargestellt was die fdp jedenfalls
unter opposition immer beklagt hat ein
verlagern ein finanzieren durch
undemokratische neben und
schattenhaushalten das ist ihre deutsche
bahn hat er gesagt das kommt mit uns
nicht
das ist genau das prinzip ich verlag
oder aufgaben außerhalb des ja ich dann
will ich noch mal klarstellen verlag
wenn sie aufgaben verlagern aufgaben
verlagern aus dem bundeshaushalt hinaus
auf bestimmte agenturen oder
einrichtungen übertragen
dann ist das in transport führt das zur
intransparenz und seinem verlust
parlamentarischer kontrolle so habe ich
sie eben verstanden als sie sagten sie
wenden sich gegen undemokratische
nebenhaushalte das ist jedenfalls mal
ein wort das ist jetzt gesprochen und
ich nehme an dass es auch steht
darum werden die
finanzierungsmöglichkeiten immer
geringer was ich begrüße das nicht schon
von beginn an getrickst wird und man
versucht etwas hinzubiegen aber wie die
aufgabe dann rein mathematisch aufgeht
das ist noch nicht andeutungsweise klar
doch und darum ist es ein starker
kontrast gegen gegenüber der
rhetorischen überhöhe was man als also
wir haben ja jahrhundert regierung
jahrhundert transformation aber wer
sozusagen als rechnen geht da ist noch
die arbeit vor den beiden so will ich so
jetzt nur weil ich einmal damit sich das
wort der jahrhundert regierung der
jahrhundert koalition nicht
verselbstständigt sagen dass im urlaub
scholz davon gesprochen hat dass die
transformation der wirtschaft aufgrund
des klimaschutzes eine
jahrhundertaufgabe ist der würde sich
jede koalition übrigens stellen ist ich
halte mal zum zweiten fest ich höre dass
sehr wohl wer norbert roth kann auch bei
den großen investitionsbedarf spricht in
der mittelfristigen finanzplanung der
von der cdu geführten bundesregierung da
entnehme ich jedenfalls nichts von
dieser dimension das sind jetzt erst
einmal der finanzdienst erst java hat
jetzt ja neue partner und das ist jetzt
an der nächste korrelation die sich dem
stellen müssen gestalten sie nochmal die
dritte bemerkung weit feststelle dass
darüber immer hinweggegangen wird die
kfw hatten sie genannt sie habe nicht
ihn schuldenbremse gewarnt
sigrid iran schreibens modell
abschreibung gestatten was anderes auch
schon angeboten vier firmen noch in
serbiens formation ja aber das ist etwas
andere hilft das heißt das beschleunige
schulden hebelt auch private
investitionen und vermindert die zu
zahlenden schulden gegebenenfalls das
historische durch wachstum ist noch
etwas anderes aber darum geht es jetzt
hier nicht mehr nur sagen dass dieses
instrument
private investitionen mit privatem
kapital zu ermöglichen bislang in
deutschland nicht hinreichend genutzt
worden nehmen wir etwa die
lebensversicherungen die viele
milliarden euro haben die dürfen ihr
kapital für bestimmte aufgaben nicht
einsetzen aufgrund von regulatorischen
vorgang und wenn es nun gelingt diese
regulatorisch zu verändern indem fällt
auch der staat bestimmte absicherungen
die gar kein geld kosten breiten stellt
dann fließt viel geld und zwar nicht nur
zum vorteil etwa der wichtigen
ökologischen vorhaben sondern auch um
eine rentierliche hre verzinsung für die
altersversorgung der menschen zu einer
öffentlichen mittel da sind ja dann
private mittel so steht es in dem
sanierungspaket das ja ich wollte hier
neben der show eröffnen neben einer
schwerpunktsetzung natürlich aushalten
lassen sie jetzt so tun als hätte es das
der vergangenheit alles geben dann frage
ich möchte sie waren in der
vergangenheit auf jeden fall festhalten
das ist einfach sicherer einen dissenz
gibt zwischen dem was man liest aus
diesem einen satz oder besser gesagt
jeder macht offensichtlich zum teil auch
daraus was er verstehen möchte mich
würde noch mal ganz kurz ich frag bei
frau berg gleich nach herfried münklers
meinung interessieren herr münster
könnte man nicht auf der anderen seite
aber auch sagen das wovor wir dastehen
diese transformation dieser komplette
umbau einer produktion und damit auch
der arbeitswelt und all der dinge die
sich verändern werden in diesem land das
ist so groß dass es auch rechtfertigen
würde sowohl im nächsten jahr zu einer
finanzierung wie zu kroner zeiten zu
greifen und zu sagen es ist im grunde
der deutschen einheit ähnlich riesig und
ähnlich wichtig gewichtig bis zu zwei
millionen geschätzt auf die nächsten
jahre und insofern würde es
rechtfertigen zu sagen klar wir brauchen
kredite wir brauchen geld
also uneingeschränkt ja
ich meine wenn man über eine
jahrhundertaufgabe spricht dann muss man
auch bereit und in der lage seien die
voraussetzungen für deren bewältigung zu
schaffen
das heißt über einen relativ langen
zeitraum ich habe dass wir hin
angesprochen als ich ein bisschen über
die narrativer etwas gesagt habe ein
länger langen zeitraum also nicht eine
legislaturperiode nur sondern mindestens
zwei ein solches projekt anzugehen und
da kommt mir jetzt ein interessanter
punkt hin so nicht die demokratie bringt
aufgrund ihrer internen mechanismen
gewiefte taktiker hervor und das können
wir im augenblick auch wenn ich so aus
münchen gewiss haben also mit einem
gewissen abstand die diskussion
beobachter sehen das sind alles gewiefte
taktiker aber was man für die
bewältigung einer solchen aufgabe
braucht ist was ganz anderes
das sind strategen und das bringt
demokratie aufgrund ihrer mechanismen
nicht unbedingt hervor und das wird man
jetzt sehen müssen ob diese koalition
nachdem sie mit der semantik in vorlage
getreten ist auch in der lage ist das
umzusetzen und dazu gehört dann auch
dass man versucht rahmenbedingungen zu
verändern
derlei mehr um das was frau in der sie
angesprochen haben nämlich ist jetzt
echt pech gewesen dass sie anfangen oder
den bedingungen von corona so zu
relativieren dass man in der lage ist
diese aufgabe wirklich anzugehen und
sich nicht durch immer wieder herein
kommende krisen und damit müssen wir
natürlich rechnen dass es in den
nächsten jahren auch der fall sein wird
wie das die zweite hälfte der ära merkel
gestimmt hat sich da nicht aus dem
konzept bringen zu lassen sondern das
langfristig zu verfolgen und da hat
sozusagen jetzt die drei sondierungs
parteien die haben diese latte hoch
gelegt wird jetzt
beobachten inwieweit sie sich aus dem
konzept bringen lassen gut dann fragen
wir bei freiburg noch einmal nach frau
bärbel sie bleiben dabei und es gibt ja
jetzt auch eine argumentative stütze
dafür zu sagen das was wir an geld
benötigen um deutschland klimaneutral zu
machen und diesen umbau zu schaffen das
haben wir und werden wir uns zur
verfügung stellen mit diesen zehn mal 50
milliarden und gegebenenfalls im
nächsten jahr mit der situation die wir
mit der ausgesetzten schuldenbremse
haben
wir können ja nicht sagen wir machen
jetzt einfach die augen zu und dann
gucken wir mal
was passiert mit der klimakrise die
klimakrise ist unsere größte
herausforderung und dies zugleich unsere
aller allergrößte chance wir sind hier
in einer situation dass wir weltweit in
einem wettstreit stehen wer entwickelt
die technologien der zukunft die
klimaneutral sind das ist eine
zukunftsinvestition die dem ganzen
gemeinsamen europäischen binnenmarkt
eben die chance gibt in diesem
jahrhundert die globale
wettbewerbsfähigkeit für europa
gemeinsam zu stärken wo wir ja auch in
einem wettstreit mit anderen regime
autoritären kräften zum beispiel in
china stehen und diese investition
müssen wir jetzt gemeinsam stemmen sich
auch deutlich geworden wir haben an ein
paar punkten noch dinge die müssen wir
gemeinsam weiter klären aber dass
sondierungs papier hat ein klares
bekenntnis dazu die aufgabe ich würde
den satz gerner zentren die aufgabe
anzugehen weil es ist nicht nur pech
dass wir jetzt in einer finanziellen
situation sind wo wir gerade stehen das
ist ja nicht nur corona sondern es liegt
daran dass in den letzten jahren wo auch
die cdu regiert hat eben diese
investitionen als wir florierende
steuereinnahmen hatten als wir eine sehr
sehr gute wirtschaftliche lage hatten
diese investitionen nicht getätigt wurde
sind und deswegen sind wir in vielen
bereich hilft jetzt zurück gefahr hilft
jetzt aber erst mal nicht beim blick
nach vorne ich habe mir den gedanken von
frau hoffmann gemerkt dass wir über die
sozialen um verteilungskämpfe noch reden
wollen und werden inklusive frau berbalk
der situation dass sie von der grünen
jugend von greenpeace von freitags fünf
user kritisiert werden für das was sie
ausverhandelt haben weil es nach
überzeugung der klimaaktivisten nicht
reicht also die zwei fragen werden wir
schaffen zu wenden und zu wägen wie
viele menschen werden sie enttäuschen in
einer ampel situation in der sie diese
klimaziele nicht schaffen weil es
rücksichten zu nehmen gibt es
geht nicht darum zu sagen wir werden die
klimaziele nicht schaffen sondern es
gibt ein klares bekenntnis in diesem
papier aber das reich und das also dass
wir auch den 1,5 grad fahrt kommen
müssen das ist unser anspruch das muss
auch unser anspruch sein und wir haben
eine menge aufzuholen und deswegen
hatten wir schon in unserem wahlprogramm
als grüne deutlich
gemacht das geht nicht mit einem
fingerschnipp und es geht nicht allein
mit nationalen maßnahmen sondern es
braucht die internationale
zusammenarbeit und deswegen ist mir so
wichtig dass wir das ganze europäisch
und international denkt und ich möchte
an diesem punkt einmal klar und deutlich
widersprechen man kann jetzt natürlich
sagen ihr macht das zauberwerk auf 16
seiten schreibt ihr schon mal alle
150 maßnahmen des klimaschutz
sofortprogramms auf das passiert aber in
koalitionsgesprächen dass wir hier getan
haben im klimaschutz teil und jeder der
sich dem jetzt mal genau anschaut der
muss dann halt auch drei sätze mehr
lesen und nicht nur idealerweise
kohleausstieg sondern wir haben da was
verankert wogegen die alte regierung
gekämpft hat nämlich den kohleausstieg
schon in den nächsten zehn jahren um
2030 zu schaffen haben sogar ein
instrument benanntes tut man
normalerweise in sondierungsgesprächen
auch noch nicht sondern haben gesagt
dafür ändern wir dass kohl
ausstiegsgesetz was die spd und die cdu
gerade vor anderthalb jahren erst
beschlossen haben wir haben gesagt zwei
prozent der landesfläche für windkraft
eine forderung für die die
umweltverbände und auch wir grünen immer
gekämpft haben wir haben gesagt das was
in baden-württemberg möglich ist dass
wir bei neuen häusern jetzt auch
solaranlagen
standardmäßig auf die dächer darauf
bringt das gehen wir jetzt alles an und
ja das wird noch nicht reichen um
komplett auf den 15 grad fahrt zu kommen
deswegen müssen wir im bereich der
industrie massiv dinge tun deswegen bis
wir im gebäudebereich ganz ganz viele
dinge tun aber was wären wir denn für
politiker wenn wir nicht sagen wir
packen das jetzt an mit allem was wir
haben selbst wenn wir keine
hundertprozentige sicherheit haben dass
es funktioniert anpacken das ist das
jetzt was wir tun müssen wie realistisch
ist es norbert röttgen das alles
zeitgleich zu schaffen auf der einen
seite natürlich eben unser mit den
freistaat bayern zu überreden dass
windräder eine tolle tolle sache sind
auf der anderen seite 2 prozent der
flächen zur verfügung zu stellen aus
sechs jahren sechs monate zu machen im
hinstellen dieser windräder
parallel dazu dafür zu sorgen dass
unmengen von strom für die deutsche
industrie vorhanden sind die trassen zu
bauen ist das alles zu schaffen und wird
es reichen um diese werte zu
also dieses 15 ziel zu erreichen also
ich stimme zu wir müssen es schaffen wir
werden es nicht alleine schaffen aber es
kommt auf uns an das ist ein
wirtschaftliches und gesellschaftliches
erfolgsprojekt wird das nur
international funktioniert da stimme ich
zu aber weil ich zustimmen ist die
ambition unzureichend und das was sie
erreicht haben auf diesem gebiet ist
nicht auf dem level was christian
lindner in seinen wichtigen bereichen
über die wir eben gesprochen haben etwa
in der steuerpolitik erreicht hat und
darum kann ich die enttäuschung von die
sie eben zitiert haben wirklich
verstehen wenn da eben idealerweise
steht dann fragt man sich ja was ist
denn das für bedingungen wenn sie sagen
wir weisen im boden 2 prozent fläche aus
haben sie ja noch kein einziges windrad
gebaut die werden hier konkret gebaut
sie haben nicht die haben immer betont
noch am wahlabend und danach es muss
eine klima regierung sein wenn ich jetzt
in diesem papier was ich drei mal
durchgelesen habe
erkenne ich nicht was ist das
markenzeichen dieser regierung in der
klimapolitik muss noch mal zu sagen in
zehn tagen beginnt der klimagipfel in
glasgow was ist die ansage der neuen
regierung für diesen gipfel sie haben
sogar einen rückschritt für den sie auch
kritisiert werden von von den aktiven
klima politisch aktiven dort vereinbart
denen ich gar nicht verstehen kann
vielleicht erklären sie bei der
gelegenheit wir haben im
klimaschutzgesetz das novelliert worden
ist im anschluss an die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgericht ein strenges
klimaschutzgesetz doch darin dass
jährlich
spezifisch auf die sektoren berechnet
bilanziert werden muss co2 angeschaut
wird und in serie firefly jahren nicht
in drei jahren jährlich und für jeden
sektor also mobilität wohnen energie
industrie jetzt vereinbaren sie und das
ein großer fortschritt weil man nicht
mehr mogeln kann und jetzt vereinbaren
sie in diesem sondierungs papier das
jährlich mehrjährig wird und dass aus
den sektorspezifische journal und
sektorübergreifende christian lindner
grinst ein bisschen aber es scheint das
nicht okay aber jetzt frage ich ja auch
nur sie wieso haben sie dem zugestimmt
das ist ein rückschritt nicht status quo
das regression des rückschritt gegenüber
der geltenden gesetzeslage das verstehe
ich nicht erklären sie mir dass man in
dem sie das nicht lesen mit einer
polemik wo sagen wann dreht jetzt jedem
satz einmal um sondern indem sie das so
lesen unter dem lichte des pariser
klimaabkommen und da wir beide sehr viel
klimapolitik gemacht haben wissen sie
ganz genau dass im pariser klimaabkommen
steht alle fünf jahre überprüfen werden
und im übrigen steht das jetzt wieder an
und wenn sie jetzt plötzlich sich so
gewandelt haben dass sie sagen
kohleausstieg 20.30 wollten wir schon
immer dann gesagt darüber dass ihr mann
sie idealerweise gesagt ich hab ihn
sogar ist ja super dass die aktuelle
bundesregierung jetzt noch nach glasgow
ist weil bis dahin werden wir die ampel
noch nicht aufgestellt haben und wenn
sie jetzt sagen das wollten wir
eigentlich schon immer na dann kann ja
jetzt ihre bundesregierung auch ihre
bundeskanzlerin hinfahren oder tagen der
wird nämlich gerne beantworten 2030
steigt deutschland aus der kohle wir
haben das in kohle ausstiegs gesetz
verankert und jetzt zu den sektoren
zählten da steht ganz klar und deutlich
drin und ich glaube das ist der respekt
in der politik dass man auch dann alle
sätze zitiert jeder sektor muss seinen
beitrag leisten ansonsten werden wenn
ich klimaneutral wärme verkehr industrie
alle müssen ihren beitrag leisten
natürlich brauchen wir das jährliche
monitoring was im klimaschutzgesetz drin
steht aber darüber hinaus müssen wir
doch wenn wir maßnahmen die wir jetzt
vereinigen zum beispiel
verbrennungsmotor aus in den nächsten
zehn jahren dann können wir doch nicht
sagen das wird morgen schon auswirkung
haben dann müssen wir doch zusätzlich
zum klimaschutzgesetz mit
berücksichtigen was diese
mittelfristigen emissionsminderungen
auch bedeuten und das ist doch dass eine
vorausschauende politik zu machen und
zusätzlich zu dem was das
klimaschutzgesetz gebietet eben diese
mittelfristigen massnahmen zu ergreifen
und die sektoren arbeiten in zukunft
zusammen wenn ein auto in zukunft
klimaneutral fährt weil es ein e auto
ist kann es zugleich eben auch als lage
säule mit funktionieren kann als
speicher mit funktionieren wenn man das
zu hause bei sich anschließt und diese
sektor übergreifende maßnahmen ja die
wollen wir in zukunft mit starken
bedenken und sie sehr gerissen sie
tricksen
unterschreiten nicht das was die große
koalition noch mit diesem
klimaschutzgesetz kurz vor dem
sommerurlaub verabschiedet hatte das was
da drin steht wird nicht in frage
gestellt ist nicht in der del
klarstellung
und entschuldigung mal ganz klar es wäre
ja absurd wenn wir das unterschreiten
würden weil ihr klimaschutzgesetz hatte
überhaupt gar keine instrumente deswegen
sind die zwei prozent bei der windkraft
deswegen ist die solarpflicht ja so
wichtig weil was sie in ihrem
klimaschutzgesetz beschrieben haben das
waren alles nur hehre ziele fragebogen
überprüfen rund die limits überprüfen
und das steht in diesem user ist und
diese stufenweise festgelegt wird es
dabei bleiben ja oder nein oder fangen
sie an diese ziele die die groko schon
bei twitter zu unterschreiten nein noch
warten die wenn wir die ziele
unterschreiten würden dann können wir
dieses ganze papier nehmen und in
mülleimer werfen wir kommen hier auf den
1,5 grad fahren wenn wir die klimaziele
an schärfen ansonsten stünde doch
deutschland nicht da also ich verstehe
ehrlich
es ist 8 und in beachtlicher punkt
zunächst ist doch mal klarzustellen dass
eine nächste bundesregierung beim
klimaschutz ambitionierter sein will als
die bisherige bundesregierung glaube das
ist klar das ist ein anliegen von
bündnis 90/die grünen und in einer
regierung in einer neuen koalition
müssen sich alle einbringen hier ist
viel von den grünen erreicht worden
nicht alles wäre jetzt schon unsere
eigene initiative gewesen aber man kommt
ja aus unterschiedlichen richtungen
zusammen das klimaschutzgesetz der
scheidenden bundesregierung
federführend auch mit von der cdu
verfasst wird aber nicht den ansprüchen
gerecht sowohl bei der ambition der
ziele als auch bei den instrumenten und
der methode und wir haben ein offenes
gespräch darüber geführt wir wollen auch
die methodik überarbeiten wir wollen
nicht fortwährend in aktionismus sondern
wir wollen um das wort von herr münkler
aufzunehmen wir wollen einen
strategischen ansatz im klimaschutz
deshalb und aus der kleinteiligkeit
herausfinden so ist dieser satz defizite
jahren zu überprüfen
und eben nicht mehr jährlich zu
überprüfen und denke dass der gast in
das sind
details in der ausformulierung niemals
zu einem späteren zeitpunkt auch
öffentlich konkretisieren